and welcome to the third special edition
of the feel the pillar series i am your
host
denisha mckerchen and i am joined by
special guests
elder randy skeet sister alana kwashi
sister chelsea jack brother kevin gomez
and sister
crystal gilbert today we will be
discussing
the millennium and answering questions
like
what is the millennium what is the
battle of armageddon
is it literal stay tuned as we answer
these questions by the grace of god and
be generous with the word feel free to
like share subscribe comment and
interact as we discuss this fundamental
belief
of seventh day adventism let us have a
word of prayer
dear lord we know that we can do nothing
without you and so we
ask for your presence and we also know
that it is impossible
for us to please you without faith so
please grant
us faith now as we have this discussion
in this q a
on the millennium and i pray for a
special anointing on your manservant
elder randy skeets and that your holy
spirit will take full possession of him
and put your words in his mouth we thank
you for also being with every other
participant
and directing this program and even the
questions that are asked
we thank you for hearing and for
answering this prayer in the name of
jesus christ
amen
well today we are joined by sister alana
kwashi and she has ministered a plethora
of times
on the word inspired you know that she
is a professional baker and founder and
manager of caked by alana
she is also studying political science
at the university of rhode island and so
she is a balanced young lady juggling
the home life the business life and
studies at just
19 years old please welcome sister alana
kwashi
as she ministers wonderful merciful
savior
[Music]
wonderful merciful
savior
precious
[Music]
the souls
comforter
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
oh
you get the healing
[Music]
foreign
hearts always
[Music]
falling before
you are the one that we
[Music]
grace are
hearts
the always that we pray
[Music]
always hunger
amen amen you give the
healing and grace our hearts
always hunger for what a wonderful
merciful savior we serve thank you
sister alana kwashi for that
outpouring of your heart in song we
appreciate
your ministry god bless you god bless
you
now we are transitioning to the q a
segment
of this program we are joined by
international speaker
elder randy skeet he's a husband and a
humble man of god and i say that
with all intentionality he is a
graduate of oakwood university and also
of the seventh day
at dentist theological seminary at
andrews university where he studied
for the ministry matthew would say i
pray
that god that i accept you pray
that god will put his words in his mouth
let us listen be reverent
and think as he speaks we welcome you
elder randy skeet and we do not
take your presence and your time for
granted we appreciate your feather for
the ministry
and the time that you spend with us
in this program thank you welcome
is there a question for me yes we have
our first question our first question is
straightforward in fact it's two-part
question number one what
is the millennium and part two is what
is its relationship
to the first and second resurrections
the word millennium means a thousand
years it's made up of two
uh latin words nearly meaning thousand
and a minute a year so it's a thousand
years the word millennium does not
actually
occur in the bible but the expression a
thousand years occurs six times
in revelation chapter 20 from verse two
down to about verse
seven and so it is a teaching of the
bible and it is a period of time that
comes between
the second coming of christ and the
third coming of christ christ comes the
second time according to second peter
chapter 3 verse 10
first thessalonians 4 16 he comes back
at that time his brightness destroys the
wicked
and he takes his redeemed with him away
to heaven
and there with him for one thousand
years actually we can go to revelation
and begin reading from verse one so that
the bible can do more talking than i do
revelation 20 reading from verse one
and i saw an angel come down from heaven
having the key of the bottomless pit
and a great chain in his hand and he
laid hold upon the dragon that's all
serpent which is called the devil and
satan
and bound him a thousand years and cast
him into the bottomless pit
and shut him up and set a seal upon him
that he should deceive
nations no more till the thousand years
should be fulfilled
and after that he must be loosed a
little seasonal small season
and so we have the introduction of the
thousand years it is connected with the
period when satan
he's chained not in literal chains of
course their change of circumstances
because all the wicked are dead
and the righteous are gone and he's
restricted this earth
and so the earth is called the
bottomless pit uh it is not actually a
pit it's just
the world in a very very dilapidated
state because
at the coming of christ cities crumble
mountains fall
islands disappear jeremiah was given a
view
of the world in this chaotic state in
jeremiah chapter 4
from verse 23 to 26 i beheld the earth
and law it was without formal void
he's describing the condition of the
earth when jesus comes
and he takes his language from genesis 1
1 the condition of the
raw matter before god formed it into
something beautiful and artistic
and so he tells us in jeremiah 4 23 i
beheld the earth and lo it was without
form and the heavens
and they had no light i beheld the
mountains
although they trembled and all the hills
moved lightly
and so the mountains were shaking
literally shaking hills would
overthrow i beheld and lo there was no
man
and all the birds of the heaven were
fled nothing was alive
that's that's the state and this is
where satan is bound with his evil
angels
for 1 000 years and so this is the
millennium
and of course while the devil is on the
earth the saints in heaven are doing
something with christ i will get to that
i'm sure
based on subsequent questions but the
millennium is a thousand year period
which stretches between the second
coming and the third coming
amen amen thank you for that that elder
skeet and i really love how you
made it clear that during the millennium
nobody is actually
no human being is roaming the earth the
righteous are
in heaven and the wicked dead are in
their graves
and we see as well that that millennium
is what separates the first and the
second resurrections
if you read verse verse 4 tells us in
verse 5
but the rest of the dead lived not again
until the thousand years were expired or
finished
and so we know the rest of the dead
meaning the wicked whom god did not take
with them
they don't live again until the thousand
years are over when christ
raises them to let them see what they're
about to get and how
just the punishment is
what a sight then holy see that hath
part
in the first resurrection on such the
second death has no power
which means the second death hath power
of those who come up in the second
resurrection
which is at the end of the thousand
years
amen amen you know what so you know as
you're talking
i'm thinking about jesus how he has
power over life and death
and those that are raised in the first
resurrection get a taste of that same
power
so if you want to really have the power
of the lord now is the time to commit
our hearts enlightenment because we do
not
want to be in that second resurrection
that's right
so the next question elder skeet as you
alluded to it before is
what takes place in the millennium all
right during the millennium
satan and his evil angels they are
confined to the earth
in second peter chapter 2 verse 4 the
bible says
for if god spared not the angels that
sinned
but cast them down to hell and delivered
them at the chains of darkness to be
reserved unto judgment
so the chains represents the
circumstances in which they find
themselves
and as i said during that thousand year
period they will be restricted to the
earth with no want attempt
no trouble to cause among humanity as we
said the wicked
are in the grave the righteous living
and righteous dead resurrected taken to
heaven
now what will they be doing in heaven we
go to
first corinthians six read verses one
and two we'll also go back to revelation
20 by the way
first corinthians 6 1 2 and 3
paul is rebuking the corinthians
pursuing one another
in the secular courts which by the way
we should not do
adventists should not sue one another
let me say that again
adventists should not take one another
the court
we should let the church handle it and
it is better to suffer a loss
than to have church members fighting
each other in a public courtroom
paul is condemning this and he says in
verse 1 let me pray again father in
heaven
as we continue this session give me
wisdom and give comprehension to your
people
in jesus name i pray amen dare any of
you
having a matter against another go to
law
before the unjust and not before the
saints
paul is saying how could you go to some
unsaved person
to settle a matter between two saved
people he tells them don't do that
do we not know that the saints shall
judge the world
that's what he's saying the question
then becomes when will the saints judge
the world
it is during this thousand-year period
that the saints will judge the world
verse 3 says
know ye not that we shall judge angels
which angels
the fallen angels this is what will take
place
during the thousand years now if we go
back to revelation
20. we read from verse 4 and i saw
thrones and they sat upon them
and judgment was given to them and i saw
the souls of them which would be headed
for the witness of jesus
and for the word of god a wish to have
which had not received his
worship the beast or his image or
received his mark upon their foreheads
in their hands and they lived and
reigned with christ a thousand years
and so part of the activity will be
reigning with christ
being involved in the administration of
the entire universe
but also based on current first
corinthians 6 1 to 3
examining the judgment that is to be
poured out upon the wicked you see
even though god is just he allows human
beings to examine his justice
before he sent the flood he talked with
noah before he destroyed salman gomorrah
he talked with abraham and before he
destroys this earth
in some way he discusses it with jesus
who represents the earth
because he was human and so god in his
mercy not
needing human support he allows humanity
to examine
the steps he has taken so that they can
be satisfied that god is a just
god and so for a thousand years we shall
be examining the lie
not as i said we i hope somebody said
amen we shall begin
in the lives of those who are lost so
that we can be
satisfied that the justice of god is
indeed just that's what we'll be doing
by the way it may be a sad time for some
of us because
tears will not yet be wiped from the
eyes because you may have to examine the
record or eye
of a lost relative or a lost friend and
the person you know what's coming for
that person
and you're looking at that person's case
so it'll be a trying time
even up there because sin is not yet
done away with
completely and so our activities will be
reigning with christ
for a thousand years and sitting with
him in judgment
the investigative judgment the father is
the judge
the judgment that takes place in a
thousand years christ
is the judge we are his assistants
amen amen thank you thank you for that
elder skeet
you know as you were talking i was just
taken aback look at the great god of the
universe
wants human beings to take part in his
work
yes in examining his judgment which we
know
is just and we are all we can also
affirm amos 3 verse 7 which says surely
the lord god will do
nothing but he revealeth his secrets
unto his servants the prophets our god
will never take a move without
informing us first so thank you for that
answer elder skeet so we'll be
judging the earth friends by god's grace
during that millennium now i'm gonna
transition and let sister chelsea jack
ask
the next three questions please welcome
sister chelsea
jack hello elder randy skeet
hello dr chelsea how are you i'm good it
is so nice all right
eat you god bless you next question is
we've actually alluded to this before
you spoke a little bit about it but can
you go more in depth
in revelation 20 verse 3 it speaks of
the devil being cast into a bottomless
pit
and seal set upon him is this a literal
event
they are not literal events now his
confinement is literal
because he cannot leave the earth
actually during the flood he could not
leave the earth either lying tells us
and he thought he would drown he was
very terrified during the flood he
thought he would drown
which means a spirit can be destroyed in
the thousand years
he is on the earth with the evil angels
whom he is used to cause
so much trouble for six thousand years
that is literal
there are no literal chains as we read
in second peter two verse 4
reserved unto judgment they put into
evil chains of darkness there are no
literal chains
but there are circumstances that he
cannot get
out of because the word of god has said
he will be
in that circumstance uh 2nd chapter 2
verse 4 reserved unto judgment
in jude which has one chapter verse 6
and the angels which kept not the first
estate but left their own habitation
he's as reserved in
darkness chains of darkness unto the
judgment now
confinement is real chains are symbolic
because revelation is largely a symbolic
book
the bottomless pit a symbolic expression
it simply means
a devastated place and as i said
if you read uh jeremiah 24 chapter 4
verse 26
all the cities are broken down that's
what he's saying at the coming of christ
this is where the death will be
restricted that is why it is called the
bottomless pit
and in the greek translation of the old
testament called the septuagint
it translated genesis 1 1 genesis 1 2
and the earth was without
form and void and darkness was upon the
face of the deep
the greek word therefore deep is abusive
which is the same word for bottomless
pit
in revelation chapter 20 1-3
so his confinement is literal but the
chains are not but he cannot leave the
earth
he has a thousand years to reflect on
all the trouble he has caused and
instigated thank you for that so the
chief
and bottomless pit are not literal and
officially symbolic expressions yes
symbolic expression
i think he needs more than a thousand
years to think about what he's done
sometimes sometimes when we talk we say
well that man is tied to his wife
now he's not literally tied but he's so
close to her
and so satan will be tied to the earth
he'll be chained to the earth because he
cannot escape it
yes thank you for that okay moving on to
the next question
what is the battle of armageddon is it
literal and what are gog
and magog the battle of armageddon is
literal in the sense that there will be
a struggle between good and evil
there won't be bombs going off and
bullets flying and land mines no nothing
of the sort
this is a spiritual battle as it was
when christ threw satan out of heaven
many many many many many years ago so it
is a literal battle
but not fought with the weapons that we
are familiar with
it is essentially a spiritual battle the
battle of armageddon takes its name from
the city of megiddo
in the middle east uh which is close to
the plane of s drylon where a lot of
significant battles were fought in the
old testament
perhaps the most significant is found in
judges chapter 4 where the israelites
fought the canaanites
and the israelite leader was bare act
and he wouldn't he didn't want to fight
but the prophetess
or the judge deborah told him he said if
you go with me
i'm going stop so she said i'll go with
you and they went
and the bible says in judges 4 16
that all the canaanites not not one man
was left
a total victory and so this is the way
the victory will be for christ in the
battle of armageddon the forces of good
led by christ will crush the forces of
evil
led by satan that's a literal spiritual
battle if i can
still steal words it is a literal
spiritual battle right now you and i
from day to day
we go through spiritual battles we can't
see the enemy but it is literal
we can see the enemy the battle of
armageddon is a battle between the
forces of good
and righteousness led by christ those
who have respected the law of god
and the forces of rebellion led by the
devil
and leading those who have chosen to
ignore
the law of god yes the weapons of our
warfare
aren't carnal but they're mighty through
god so in that time we'll have to stay
on our knees we have to pray we have to
fast
we have to spite fight spiritually
that's no joke my sister we really have
to do that
yes even in today's day and age we don't
gotta wait
but we have to learn now especially in
today's day and age
especially since we're about to enter a
time of trouble
since such as the world has never seen
especially in this day and age we have
to be spiritually alert
yes okay so the next question is
when does the judgment of the wicked
take place
the judgment of the wicked occurs during
the thousand years the investigative
judgment as the bible scholars prefer to
call it
the pre-advent judgment is a judgment
going on right now
because when christ comes the righteous
will come from their graves
immortal in order to come from the grave
immortal once you come from the grave
immortal
there's no need for a judgment for you
someone has already decided
that's how you'll come up first
corinthians 15 51 to 55
the dead shall be raised incorruptible
they can no longer die
they come up with immortality well who
decided that
it had to be decided before they were
raised and so there is
a judgment going on now it is the
judgment on
those who claim to have been a part of
the house of god
first peter chapter 4 verse 17 for the
time is come the judgment
must begin at the house of god the house
of god means those who have professed
some sort of relationship with god
the house of god has wheat and tears but
they are the house of god
and the judgment is to decide who is the
we and who is the tear
when that is finished that's when jesus
comes back and when we get to heaven
with him
then we begin the judgment of the wicked
now let me be clear
the judgment of the wicked is different
from the judgment of the just
the judgment of the just or the house of
god is to decide
who was really faithful who was not then
decisions are made as to who will be
saved who will not
the judgment of the wicked is not to
decide who will be saved
the fact that it did not come up in the
first resurrection
is all the proof we need that they are
already lost
the judgment is for the redeemed and for
angels and for unfallen worlds to see
that god's judgment against the wicked
was
just that throughout eternity
or since the controversy began god has
always been just because eloise tells us
it was only when some angels saw
what satan did to christ on the cross
that they finally cut off all sympathy
with him
up to that point some angels still
believe he had been unfairly treated
if you read 1st peter chapter 1 verse 12
it tells us at the end of verse 12
which stains the angels desire to look
into angels do not understand everything
and since we're heading for a world
where sin will never return
everyone has to be absolutely convinced
that sin is a bad thing and
righteousness is the way to live
and so it takes a thousand years for us
the unfallen worlds and the angels to
see
that god is just that is why before the
wicked destroyed
after the thousand years before satan's
destroyed every
lost person will bend the knee and say
that jesus christ is lord they will
agree
that god was right in his judgment and
then they'll be destroyed
and so the judgment of the wicked is not
to decide who will be lost that's
already decided
by their own choice the judgment of the
wicked is for the redeemed to sit with
christ
and examine the records and to see
that the punishment they're about to
receive is just now let me say something
else
there's a difference between punishment
and wages but they're all connected
the wages of sin is death but
according to luke 12 42 to 48
some are beaten with many stripes some
are beaten with few stripes
the more wicked you are the more you
suffer before you die
now this is not the sort of thing people
want to hear they want to hear how to
get rich how to get a husband or wife
but the bible has many many things we
need to be familiar with
even the most familiar first in the
bible has death and life
for god so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth in him should
not perish what does perish mean
burn in the fires of hell but have
everlasting life
a life with god and so in that thousand
years we will see
that various periods of suffering will
be assigned to different people
and we know that satan will burn the
longest before he finally perishes
he burns the longest clearly because he
said
some people the moment the fires hit
them they consumed because their lives
were not that wicked
so we have differences in suffering
before the final blotting out
but all will finally die because the
wages of sin is death
and so the bible says behold i come
quickly and my reward is with me to give
every man
according as his work shall be if you've
been very very wicked
you suffer more before you die remember
suffering is attached both to salvation
and to damnation because jesus suffered
and the loss will suffer similarly
sorry for that bones oh there's no
problem this is what we're here for
um but i thank you for that explanation
really i did not know before i read um
the truth about angels by elena
i didn't know that the angels you know
sympathize with satan
and really white also said that we're
living this life for
self-revelation so god doesn't know
who's not going to die
or who's not going to go to hell but
he's doing it so we can see with our own
eyes why made a certain choice um and
yes definitely the wicked will be
destroyed and the righteous will help um
jesus
judge yeah so the last question that i
have is
based on revelation 21 verse 2 we know
that new jerusalem descends from heaven
to earth after the millennium
but in the earth when hell fire comes
down
yes it is it comes down on mount of
olives the mountain splits
a part of that earth is made holy and
sacred that's where the city sits
when the earth is consumed with fire
revelation 20
verse 9 and 10 the fires burn all around
the city
and eloise tells us while the fires are
burning the save that's us
will be in the city safe and secure uh
great controversy page 673 paragraph
three
the redeemed will be in the earth in the
in the city
watching this global conflagration they
will be safe
from the fire the wicked will be
consumed and it will take several days
for the fire to finally
do its work because it burns up the
earth physically
it burns up the atmosphere it burns up
the spirit beings
and the different flames of burning
differently you know there's some i
wonder if i should tell you this is so
it's so frightening but ly says as long
as a little part of you is left that is
not consumed
you feel all the agony of the burning so
if the only thing left to burn is a
fingernail
you feel it as though all of you is
still burning it's
hell is no place to be that's why she
says we have a heaven to gain
and a hell to shun let me say people do
not like to hear these things
they find them depressing but there's
something called negative motivation
negative motivation means i don't want
to go to hell and there's nothing wrong
with that
and we have medical negative motivation
in john 3 16
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish and so i have a reason to be
saved i want to be with jesus
but i also do not want to go to hell
my major reason is jesus but i don't
want to go to hell
and so eloise said we have a heaven to
gain and the hell to
shine actively on hell
you must actively shun hell shining hell
does not happen automatically
you must actively shun hell and
everything that is hellish
thank you for that we do not want to be
in hell guys no
no you don't let's do what we have to do
now and
just before i go me and my mother we
were talking about the judgment and i
literally
told her that jesus is the shield the
difference between the
the righteous and the wicked is
literally jesus
so wicked just rejected their shield
from god's wrath that's right
that's right but guys there's nothing
we can do jesus did everything thank you
of the randy skeet it was a pleasure
questioning you i will turn it back to
denisha all right ah thank you so much
elder skeet and sister
chelsea for those couple of questions
and answers friends we gotta take and
hold on to that negative motivation
we do not want to ex no we do not want
to experience
hell fire and i have some other
questions um written up but i see that
christine sister christina has asked
in response to one of the answers that
was given doesn't mean that when i die
now
god forbid i either die a saint or a
sinner
everyone dies that way your idea died
saved or lost that decision is
made at resurrection it is made before
you die some people make that choice for
themselves
by rejecting christ others they claim to
follow christ you know uh titus chapter
1 verse 16
they profess that they know god but in
works they deny him they're people of
that description
when you die that's it there is no
opportunity for repentance when you rise
because christ does not come as a priest
he comes as a king
and so when you die yes that's it you
either saved or lost
but you make that decision before you
die you understand
you know you're not lost because you die
you you chose to live a life that caused
you to be lost you chose to be lost
and you die in that condition or you
chose jesus and you die in that
condition
blessed are the dead which die in the
lord to die in the lord you must first
live in the lord
to die outside of the lord you must have
chosen to live outside of the lord
before you die
nothing happens in the great it happens
before we hit the grace
well friends god is definitely not a
procrastinator if he's coming with our
reward
that means that he has made the decision
about our
state whether a sinner or a saint
beforehand and it's based on our
choices so thank you for that response
elder skeet
now someone else has asked galaxy j2 and
i i reckon i believe
i believe chelsea had asked this
question a time before will you know if
you are saved before jesus comes back
how will we know you you're supposed to
know that you've given your life to
christ
now that you know that's the safety
thing you can say i have
and this has to be done dearly you
surrender the life to christ
daily you you know i have given my life
to christ
you know i'm trying by the indwelling
power of his spirit to obey him
you know that and that's the safest
thing you can say
you don't remember saying i'm saved i'm
saved you can say i have given my life
to christ
and the life in the hand of christ
cannot be lost
let me say it again a life that is given
to christ
cannot be lost so you can know i've
given my life to christ and i keep
renewing that surrender
hello white rights and desire of adhd
324 paragraph one
we may leave off many habits for a time
we may part company with satan
but without a vital connection with god
through surrender of ourselves to him
moment by moment
we shall be overcome without a vital
connection with god
through surrender of ourselves to him
moment by moment
we shall be overcome in steps of christ
page 48 paragraph one
and thus through constant surrender to
god you will be enabled to live in your
life the life of faith we don't
understand the concept of
constant surrender
because the devil is our heels all the
time
the surrender must be constant so you
and i can say
i gave my life to christ the moment i
opened my eyes before i left the bed i
did not wait to kneel
in that bed i gave my life to christ and
i renewed during the day
how long does it take to say father i
resubmit my life to your control
three seconds um
hallelujah constant surrender
the life on automatic pilot is a
conscious experience
it's intentional and deliberate
amen intentionality is what god desires
of us
and you know as i was reflecting one day
the lord revealed to me that being a
christian
is not about giving up things not doing
things anymore being a christian is
about giving our all to god
christ without exception without
reservation
when when the bible says thou shalt love
the lord thy god with all thy heart with
all thy soul with all thy mind with all
my strength
that's no joke all all
you can't give one percent of the devil
a 99 for god
that's like one drop of poison in a
bottle of vitamin and rich water
it's all bad it must be a total
surrender to god
total surrender amen well friends we
want to surrender all to our savior
and lord everything we want to lay it on
the altar of sacrifice
the reason why god must total surrender
from us is because he made total
surrender for us
in giving christ that was total
surrender for
us there was no other way we could be
saved but by the
total surrender of god in jesus christ
that's why the bible says god was
in christ reconciling the world unto
himself god
gave himself when he gave jesus christ
mysterious because it was christ who
died
but in some way that's very very real
the father
gave it and i say that because the bible
says uh john 15
verse 13 greater love has no man than
this that a man lay down his life for
his friends
it doesn't say a greater love hath no
man than this that a man lay down
someone else's life for his friend the
greatest expression of love is the
sacrifice of your own life
god said the bible says for god soul of
the world that he gave his only begotten
son wait a minute if you love me so much
why did you give somebody else why did
you give yourself when he
gave himself we better fully understand
how
he gave himself in giving christ
as i said earlier god was in christ
reconciling the world unto himself he
gave himself through christ and it's a
mystery we will study for eternity
when we get to the other side but total
surrender from us
must match total surrender from god for
our salvation
total sacrifice when i say match it
can't be matched in quality
but it must be matched in totality
insofar as a human being can surrender
himself completely
because god gave completely of himself
we have completely from heaven
completely from earth that's how
salvation works
amen amen elder skeet you know as you're
talking about giving your all my mind
goes back to the story of the widow with
the two mites
although the pharisees and the jews may
have been dropping their talents
she gave two mice but jesus said she
gave more because she gave
her all and we know that god wants us to
reciprocate the love that he expresses
in fact ellen white often writes about
you know this law of physics called
action reaction so for
every action that is put forth there's
an opposite reaction that takes place
with the same magnitude but the opposite
direction
so as god condescended and he sent his
son he expects
us to rise to the occasion and express
his love
not only to him but to our fellow men
that's right
now i see galaxy j2 you have raised
your hand on this zoom platform so if
you have your question
you are free to unmute and ask it now
thank you very much denisha um
as i i had that thought in mind and you
begin
answering the question however i'll just
rephrase it
a little bit um usually i
i would um have a torch on
uh it seems to be a progression
on growth and i would use the word
intemperate um it might seem
simple but yet uh ellen white said that
we in order to get to heaven we must
overcome every temptation
or every uh weakness she put it that way
um no i want you to give your take
on interpret in terms of
uh overeating under eating over sleeping
under sleeping little things that we uh
look
at very simple but yet still it
is uh a challenge that we must
overcome if you let me hear your take on
it please
well i don't have a take i'll tell you
what the bible says
let me pray father in heaven as we
continue let the spirit of truth direct
my mind and the minds of all those
listening and speaking
in jesus name i pray amen we talk about
little things
what was the big thing adam did adam
consume the fruit
it might have been a great a little
thing that's what he did
the point is god said don't do it
whether big or small most catastrophes
occur
they have small beginnings the kingdom
of god is like a grain of mustard seed
but the kingdom of satan is also like a
grain of mustard seed
because just one sin one
wrong thought that is not confessed
eventually neutralizes all the power of
the gospel so whether it's eating or
drinking or dressing
at all times our motivation must be the
glory of god
whether therefore ye eat or drink or
whatsoever you do
do all to the glory of god it does not
require a major catastrophic act
to endanger a person's spirituality it
can be small
but if it is done and it's done
deliberately
and not for the glory of god it
endangers the soul of the person
so overeating is wrong over sleeping or
whatever under sleep is wrong all these
things are harmful to us
spiritually and we must remember we
serve a god
in whom is no sin if god put adam out of
the garden for one sin he cannot admit
you with one on your soul
and so yes our desire must be total
victory but
if you die before the total victory is
actually achieved
christ's righteousness makes up for the
deficiency as eloise
makes so very clear when it is in the
heart to do
right to obey god and when efforts are
put
forth towards this end god accepts this
as your best service
and he makes up for the deficiency with
his own divine merit
and so it begins in the heart of a
person with all my heart and soul
i want to stop smoking but he's battling
a habit he's had for 50 years
he cannot conquer it between monday and
tuesday but in his heart is a perfect
desire
so the bible says david's heart was
perfect towards god it doesn't mean he
never committed mistake
but his heart was always to do the
things that please god
that's the heart he had even though he
made mistakes from time to time
and so in temperance my brother whether
in big things or little things
in temperance is catastrophic to the
soul and it lies at the foundation of
all the moral evils known to man we must
conquer
one day at a time we must conquer one
moment at a time
through the power of christ who
conquered when he was tempted to take to
change stones
into bread by saying that victory is
ours to appropriate
that we may be victorious as he was
amen elder gilbert i discerned your
voice i
i see you have said amen amen well said
and wasan i see you say amen this
strengthens my faith in god thank you
both for
tuning in now elder skeet i have one
last question
that i've written on the millennium and
then we'll transition fully to the open
forum
all right now second peter chapter three
verse eight tells us that
one day with the lord is as a thousand
years
and a thousand years as one day we know
that the earth is about 6 000 years old
according to the the genealogies written
in the bible and also the writings of
ellen white
this question is how does the millennium
this thousand years
relate to the rest the earth is to
experience
well the earth the rest is that there's
no
sin being committed there's no
temptation going on
the earth is in a state of rest from all
the moral turmoil that has been
occurring for 6 000 years
as a result of adam having submitted to
satan's whatever
wilds and guiles so if that's a thousand
years
we otherwise frequently refers to for
six thousand years this has happened
for six thousand years she says that
frequently and since i believe she's a
genuine servant of god i take that
seriously it does not lead me to set a
date by any means i said no dates
but i do believe we're not we're not far
from the end because the final events
will be very few and very rapid and so
the thousand years
uh yes on this earth there's no there's
no one alive
just the devil and his angels no one to
tempt nothing to do just to think and
think of thing
and so there is in some sense a period
of rest
not perfect rest because perfect rest
requires the absence of sin
and all the evidences of sin so even the
christian
has not yet experienced perfect rest
because he or she
is still living in a world of sin living
in a world with prisons and hospitals
and war and disease and plague and prove
it like an ebola virus
zika whatever else so in that sense we
have not yet entered fully into god's
rest
it is when christ comes the third time
destroys the wicked burns of the earth
and the heavens restores
everything brand new then we will
finally
enter into that rest but for the
thousand years there is some sort of
rest from all the sins that are normally
committed
amen and you know i'm seeing the
intersection between the sabbath day of
rest and also the rest
from sin i'm thinking about hebrews
chapter 4
um verses 1 through 11 where where god
literally says that because of
unbelief the israelites did not enter
into the promised land
and then we also hear about god creating
the seventh day and how
there remaineth a rest for the people oh
god you see this is how beautiful on uh
the sabbath is so beautiful not only
arrests from physical labor but
also from this from the chains of sin
and from the the inclination to go
against god friends
we want that rest when jesus comes a
third
time thank you for answering yes they
did not enjoy perfect rest because they
did not cast out
all the tribes as god told them so there
was there was still
occasional harassment from time to time
so they did not
fully enjoy the rest god intended for
them again it was because of unbelief
they did not do what god said
and so let me stress again total rest
will come
when sin and all its and these
consequences
are finally blotted out and we live in
the new heavens
and the new earth wearing breath
righteousness
amen amen thank you so much elder skeet
now we have a couple of questions in the
chat and i'll start with the one
from sister cindy p and she asks
what happens to those from other
religions i believe this is what this
was in reference to the judgment
what happens to those from other
religions
what happened to the what happens to
them from other religions
i suppose is that she said
there are some people who believe all
non-adventists will be lost
some people believe that why they
believe that i don't know now
salvation and damnation is not based on
religious affiliations
necessarily it is based on your
relationship to jesus christ
of course christ requires obedience
don't misunderstand me
in in acts chapter 10 34 35 bible says
then peter opened his mouth and said
of the truth i perceive that god is no
respecter of persons
but in every nation he that worketh
righteousness
feareth god and worketh righteousness is
accepted with him now the greek word for
nation is ethnic or ethnos i think it is
which
gives us the word ethnicity so in every
ethnicity
then we extend it to every religious
group
there are those who have a heart for god
and when god calls they'll come now
they're those who live
before the holy place the most holy
place was opened and the light of the
lord
shone out they live before that they
will also be saved that includes martin
luther those were formers husty roma i
believe elright mentions them
they'll be saved since the most holy
place was opened in 1844 october 22
the light of the sabbath went out and
people had to make decisions
but wherever there's genuine ignorance
but a heart to serve god based
on all the person knows there is
salvation you see because god doesn't
judge you based on how much you know he
judged you based on
your response to what you know if you
know this he expects that if you know
this he expects that from you
and so it is not who is in another
denomination
it is what is the person's relationship
to christ
this is number one now surely we know
from uh
john chapter 10 verse 16 other sheep i
have which are not of this fold them
also i will bring
and they will i must bring they will
hear my voice there shall be one for one
shepherd we know that we know the loud
cry of revelation 18 1 to 4
targets the invisible remnant in the
other churches
that's why the cry has come out of her
my people we know that
but it's also true there are many people
of other denominations who have died
not having received certain specialized
biblical knowledge but they
loved god to the extent of the knowledge
they had
and they'll be safe when jesus comes but
christ has a remnant on the earth
he really does he has a remnant on the
earth
cornelius had a heart for god he did not
know the true god
that jesus sent peter there are people
in that condition
and so i don't want to stress other
religions i wanted to stress
what is your attitude your relationship
to jesus
christ
i saw what will happen to you i'm not
sure if it's you
no muslim i have another program right
after you another question
for the church uh in jamaica the
question may have come from them i think
it is what happens to 12 year olds i
believe it is one of their questions not
you so we'll skip that for now
all right amen okay and i
accidentally skipped this question this
is from ingrid l
she sees believers say i want to be in
that number
which number is being referred the 144
000 or the great multitude which no man
could number as found in revelation 7.
either one either one you're saying
now there's some people have heard
they'd love to be among the 144 000 that
are alive
on the earth when jesus comes that
number that goes through the time of
trouble such as the world has never seen
now i'm not sure people understand what
they're asking for
when they ask for that because the time
will trouble will be
terrible god will put a lot of his
people to sleep because they
cannot handle it so it sounds lovely to
say i
want to be among the 144 000 but
remember when jesus was in gethsemane he
asked the father get me out of this
and in a certain sense the 144 000 will
be going through that
jacob's time of trouble a suffering that
requires a special brand of faith
and so whether it's a great multitude
144 000
wherever you locate yourselves you're
safe
but trust me close to jesus you see
that's the point
get close to christ one
day at a time these future projections i
want to be in 144 000
in the year 2026 no get close to christ
now and he will determine whether he
allows you to go through
or he puts you in the grave to see but
that's his choice
amen to say ingrid i see that you have
raised your hand do you have a follow-up
question that you would like to ask you
can unmute now and ask it
hi thank you so much um and
uh i want to also thank you for allowing
me to be a part of this
zoom i'm happy to reach out
to elder skeet i've been following you
but i always have questions and i can
never ask you directly
but this question on the 144 versus the
multitude had me in a bit of a panic
because i i've recently um
i've i've grown up a seventh day i was
raised in the seventh day adventist
church
but a couple of years ago i realized
that
i have not been following god as i
should
my study has been uh getting deeper and
so i be
this fear arose in me that wait a minute
it's 144
that's only going to be saved and i said
wait a minute
and so i asked around and they said no
no no no there's also
a multitude so i'm a little confused
you know i mean i heard what you said
just get close to god get right with god
the fear and the sense of urgency is
still there so i need some
clarification on
walk and um because there's a lot of
things that i'm
not doing like this gentleman is saying
about eating i
i'm i'm learning that there's you can
also idolize food
yes and so which is a problem that i
have
and so these are the things that i'm
learning and i'm like wow you know
i i've raised in the church but i'm only
just now
beginning to learn about this
so please if you had anything additional
in explaining um um
how to be saved and what should we do
as believers or you know and just trying
to
and get a closer walk with god that
would be much appreciated thank you
how to be saved is simple
paul told the jailer in philippi
belief on the lord jesus christ and thou
shalt be saved on thy house
believe on the lord jesus which means to
totally accept his sacrifice accept him
his sacrifice as sufficient payment for
sin
you accept that when the israelites were
bitten by snakes in a numbers 21
from verse 4 down to verse 9 god told
moses director servant of the brass put
on the pole
and anyone who looked at that serpent
would be delivered from the effects of
the poisonous bite
they had to look but they had to look in
faith recognizing the serpents
symbolized christ who would be raised on
the pole
thousands of years later so when we read
john 3 16 for god so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth in him that
text is drawn from that event in numbers
21 so we can say
that whosoever looketh on him we're
saved by
looking to jesus isaiah 45 22
look unto me and be safe all the ends of
the earth salvation does not lie
in how much you drink and how much you
eat even though those things are
expressions
of your relationship with god but we
must get to the kernel the heart of the
matter is
you are saved by jesus christ and you're
saved when you
give yourself to him he's already
provided a probationary period
he's kept off the the condemnation of
the law by keeping you alive
that's probation now you've got to
respond to that by giving your life to
him when you do that sincerely my sister
christ puts in you a principle that
tricks
takes you to righteousness and draws you
from sin he
puts in you he alone can put it he puts
in you
when you totally surrender a new
principle of life
that makes righteousness attractive and
sin
a horrible thing without that principle
you can live a decent life you cannot
live a safe life that peace is god
as you daily surrender to god as
you stay in his word because the power
of god is in his word the very power of
god
the word changes you gradually it does
not happen overnight you said you have a
problem with food
ii peter 3 18 but grow in grace and in
the knowledge of our lord and savior
jesus christ it is a growth but at
every stage of that growth there must be
a perfect desire
in your heart to please god and to allow
god to lead your life
and so there need not be any fear if
you're fearful you've got to confront
second timothy chapter 1 verse 7 for god
hath not given us the spirit of fear
but of power and of love and of a sound
mind the question then
where did you get that fear it is not
from god there's only one other source
and it's not a pleasant thing to say
you've got to get rid of that by
surrendering totally
understanding you are saved by jesus
when you give yourself to him if you
truly do that
he will change your desires he will
change your life and your dislikes
he will change your appetite remember
the very first promise of the bible
genesis 3 15 i will put enmity between
thee and the woman
ask god to put hatred in your heart for
whatever dietary problems you have
ask god to give you the victory because
you are his child remind him
that the very first promise of the bible
is to put into the heart of people
a hatred for the things of the enemy and
as a child of god
god is obligated to fulfill his word to
you and so don't live in fear
there's no fear in salvation fear is in
being separated from christ the life you
live
must be surrendered to him totally
perhaps you've not surrendered
the eating part of your life to christ
perhaps you haven't because maybe some
people like what they do
yes i love jesus i love jesus but i want
to run my romantic life
i love jesus i love jesus but i want him
to tell me how to dress
so we have this negotiated relationship
with christ
you must surrender completely and that's
where most of us fall down
we select we surrender mostly we do not
surrender completely
every aspect of your life must be placed
under the control of jesus christ when
that is the case
you will be shocked how christ himself
will change you
but his avenue of change is the word uh
christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
one the scriptures are the great agency
in the transformation of character
jesus prayed sanctify them through thy
truth and so you give your life to
christ you get into the word
because the cleansing power is in the
word of god
that's why jesus told his disciples in
john 15 3
now you clean through the word which i
have spoken unto you
ephesians 5 26 27 that he might sanctify
and cleanse it with the washing of water
by the word
surrender get into the word and christ
will
change you he will give you victory over
every debilitating habit you have
whether it be diet or dress or whatever
else
there's no need to be afraid when you're
the hands of christ
hallelujah thank you for that robust
answer elder skeet sister ingrid and
those of you that may have had
um a similar longing i pray that
your question has been answered and
elder skeet i think you have effectively
answered this next question
that sister sasha shay weeks has asked
which is how do we overcome sin
that seems to constantly repeat itself
how do we die fully to self and be truly
repentant
how did jesus overcome sin by the word
of god
when he was first tempted it is written
he was tempted again it is written he
was tempted again it is written
what does psalm tell us psalm 119 verse
11 thy word have i hid in my heart that
i might not sit against the first line
wherewith all shall a young man cleanse
his ways by taking heed therefore
according to thy word now if adam had
taken heed to god's word
and he did thou eat his throat thou
shalt surely die we would not be
dispositioned
he and eve drifted from the word of god
and sin
overthrew them the conquest of sin is in
the
constant surrender of the life to christ
and living in
the word of god and by every word
constant surrender
so the and through the word accessing
that divine power
through the word of god through the
promises of god let me repeat my words
accessing divine power only divine power
can give me victory over sin
let me say it again only divine power
it is accessed through the word listen
to this quotation from ella white
education page 126 paragraph four the
creative energy that called the worlds
into existence
is in the word of god this word imparts
power
it begets life every command is a
promise
accepted by the will receive into the
soul
it brings with it the life of the
infinite one it
transforms the nature and recreates the
soul in the image of god what does that
the same powder said let there be light
and light came
that power will transform
the nature and recreate the soul in the
image of god as verily
as plant life and animal life were
created by the word
a new life is created in us by the word
and constant surrender to the word
himself which is jesus christ
amen amen well elder skeet the time is
now three o'clock p.m
another thing we must consider in
confidence and avoid situations that
lead to sin
so when god described job to the devil
he said hast thou considered my servant
job
a perfect and an upright man one that
filled with god and
is true with evil we must learn to avoid
circumstances
that make it more likely for us to fall
into sin because the devil is a master
of
entrapment we must avoid the situations
that make it easy to sin
amen amen so christ gives us power and
we also have the power of choice
amen now elder skeet i i know you have
your program in jamaica it's up to you
i'll take a couple more questions all
right so let me take the
question from youtube sister well
sterling cox's axe are there any parts
of the bible
that no longer apply to us sterling cops
that name is so familiar
anyway okay are there any parts of the
bible that no longer apply to us
the bible says in second timothy chapter
3 verse 16 all scripture is given by
inspiration of god and is profitable for
doctrine for reproof
for correction for instruction and
righteousness it didn't say some
it said all now a historical event may
no longer
apply but there are lessons to be
learned
the moment you say this does not apply
then you can apply that catastrophic
thinking to the entire bible
so we take the bible as god's gift to us
because god decided you need this old
and new and we take it
amen amen thank you all just keep i'm
going to kind of combine two questions
because i think they're similar um
sister beverly has axed on
on zoom how does god judge between
excuse me how does god judge
children who may die before they
understand
right from wrong and i'm just gonna
access
the second question so you can see the
connection which is from mark anthony
cromwell
for the sherlock will my twin siblings
who died before birth
be resurrected during the second coming
kind of similar but
you can all tell you is what god told
moses when moses said i beseeched
let me pray again father as i continue
to answer questions from your beloved
people
give me simple wisdom i pray in jesus
name amen
in exodus 33 verse 11 the bible says
this is moses speaking
and he said i beseech you show me thy
glory
and he said i will make all my goodness
pass before thee
and i will proclaim the name of the lord
before thee and i will be merciful to
whom i will be merciful and will show
will be gracious to whom i will be
gracious and will show mercy under my
will shall mercy
god is a merciful god remember he's not
willing that and he should perish second
peter chapter three verse nine
first timothy chapter two verse four we
will have all men to be saved and to
come unto the knowledge of the truth so
it's much more
likely that god will do something to
save them than that he will let them
perish that's the limit of my wisdom
based on the fact that god does not like
to see people perish
ezekiel 33 11 as i live saith the lord
say unto them
say to them as i lift saith the lord i
have no pleasure in the death of the
wicked
god does not like to see people lost
calvary is proof of that
and so while i don't know precisely what
will happen to the twins who perish in
the womb
or who died one month outside of the
womb we serve a god who prefers to
save than to lose ultimately
amen amen and i think for mothers of
little babies
who passed away it could be that what
happens to you
may affect the baby it could be but i
don't want to speculate it's not safe
i will say we serve a merciful god who
loves to save and he does not
punish people for ignorance at the time
of ignorance
amen amen and i think that well that
answers sister beverly's question in
terms of children who may not understand
right from wrong
god does not punish ignorance in fact he
calls
the hell fire his strange work yes yes
yes
yes doesn't punish ignorance doesn't
mean he likes ignorance he doesn't like
it either that's why you constantly find
particularly this in the epistles
to know to know to know i want you to
know
i want it god wants us to know but in
genuine ignorance god is very
compassionate
amen amen now elder skeet i'm gonna make
these
two last questions we have three
questions but i'm gonna just use two
all right um so one question is
it from tta adventist ascent association
they ask
a remnant religion or a remnant people
so i guess is
is there a remnant religion or is it
just a remnant people
both there's a remnant religion why
revelation 12 17 and the dragon was
wrath with the woman
and went to make what was the remnant of
a seed which keep the commandments of
god and have the testimony of jesus
those are the fundamental elements of
the religion of course it's not religion
that saves us it is jesus christ
but christ started the church on the
earth with the twelve disciples
the israelites and the wilderness were
called a church by
stephen in his great sermon in acts
chapter 7 and so
yes it's a church it's a religion it's a
people
it's a people that practice a religion
and the religion is righteousness
and the concise expression of
righteousness the ten commandments
and the living flesh and blood
expression of that
is the life of christ which must be
reproduced in us so yes there's a
remnant people
there's a remnant religion and the
religion stems all the way back from
that pure church
which keep the commandments of god and
have the testimony of jesus christ yes
and the faith of jesus revelation 14 12.
amen amen thank you now sister cassandra
james i'll make this the last question
she asks how excuse me shall the people
of god
escape the prosecution if they were to
remain
i think that means persecution if they
were to remain in the city
since we were admonished to leave since
we
were admonished to leave sorry let me
read that again am i set up
shall the people of god escape execution
if they were if they were to remain in
the city
since we were admonished to leave
the jews the christians in jerusalem
between 80 66 and 8070
they would manage to leave when god
caused the romans to withdraw
mysteriously for them but god was under
control the christians left
the city and moved to the hills and the
mountains not one perished
if god sent us a message to his servant
leave the cities
and we choose to stay doesn't mean we'll
be lost but we will suffer unnecessarily
so if she says leave leave when god
delivered a lot from sudden lot tall god
told him go to the mountains he said let
me go to zoa
so god said okay go ahead he went to zoa
then he finally left for the
the mountain eventually so god's way was
best for him
if god says leave the cities leave
you make an individual decision to leave
don't leave if others are leaving
leave because god has convicted you
because convicts
us at different times under different
circumstances you've got to make an
individual decision
mind character and personality volume 2
page 4 23 paragraph
2 the gospel deals with individuals and
so if
you're convicted leave and if it's god's
will for you to leave
he will make the way but if you stay
where god has told you to leave
you open yourself to unnecessary
suffering i'm not saying you'll be lost
but you'll be saved painfully
amen amen thank you and i i see
um note 10 plus this is actually brother
danny from stream facts many of you may
follow stream facts
um he he wrote here please help me to
know if i can write exams on the sabbath
or not and why i believe
no no no exams are good but they're not
holy
you have six days to write exams write
them from sunday to friday
ask for an exemption if you don't get
the exemption honor god
god is not to be obeyed based on
negotiation we honor him no matter what
and so ask get a letter from your
conference or your union or the vision
whomever
do all you can to be relieved
or released from sabbath exams and
sabbath classes if
all of that fails you take a stand for
god
be faithful to god and remember first
samuel 2 30
them that honor me i will honor but
since
the purpose of our lives is to honor god
first put him first
don't be intimidated by what you imagine
the consequences to be
obey god regardless remember the message
to the church and smyrna be thou
faithful unto death and i will give the
account of life
no exams on sabbath no classes nothing
of the kind is a holy day
and by refusing you may lead someone to
christ as they view your stand for truth
amen amen elder skeet thank you so you
even ended up answering a third question
i can i can tell i can tell you all from
experience i have two when i was taking
my shsat
um the exam needed to go from middle
school to high school
it was on sabbath i asked my guidance
counselor for a letter she wrote me a
letter
and i took my exam on sunday and frankly
there were a whole bunch of other jews
that did the same
so seven-day adventists don't feel
isolated and the same was for the s.a.t
there is always a way and if god chooses
to close the door and they say no you
cannot take the exam
on a day except for the sabbath that's
elders he said stand
for god stand for god
all right everyone elder skeet we cannot
thank you
enough it's all right your sacrifice of
time we know that
you've had programs back to back to back
and yet
spend the time with us and even go over
time we we
do not underestimate your presence with
us and we ask that god would be with you
as you also go forth
to answer the questions for the program
for jamaica and we continue
to pray for your strength and your vigor
may the lord renew
your strength i want you to mount up
with wings as
eagles thank you so much who said she's
fearful
please read steps to christ chapter five
steps to christ chapter five read it
microscopically
then read it again but pray before you
read ask god to open your eyes
read steps to christ chapter read the
whole book but particularly
chapter five amen sister ingrid had said
has said
okay thank you and sister shea has said
yes
ingrid it's a great book steps to christ
chapter five
thank you oh wasan would like to know
where we can watch the jamaica program i
guess
yes or no and that's it if i guess with
mission i'll send it to you by a text
document
i'm a christian and you can give it to
your people beautiful thank you
quickly you call the name sterling cox i
uh i was at school with a gentleman by
that a very nice fellow i don't know if
he's the same person many people have
same name but in case he is god bless
you god bless you god bless you nice to
hear your name being spoken
amen amen thank you so much oh this kid
so sterling cox
elder skeet remembers you and whether
it's the same person or not
yes you hate your presence ellis we
don't want to hold you any longer we are
just so grateful that you've spent this
time with
us may the lord continue to bless you
and your wife and thank you sister
chelsea jack for putting
the youtube um link in the zoom chat yes
this program is also live stream to
youtube as well as facebook and you can
watch
the replay by clicking on the link in
the zoom chat
where is that young man who's usually
with you very nice fellow
i didn't this time i don't remember his
name but the nice
sharp looking fellow the one that hosted
last week or
the one that oh where the jonathan for
the jonathan archie
where is he you know i do
i don't know that's fine that's fine
tell him he was pissed and somebody
asked about it
oh i will do that i will do that elder
skeet
i know sometimes he has to play for
other churches play piano for other
churches and he also speaks so
i don't know if that may have caused him
to not be here but thank you for
for recognizing him eldest
all right everyone yes let me say prayer
then i'll run away
amen father in heaven thank you again
for the glorious privilege of
enjoying religious freedom we thank you
god that the spirit i
guide just as we genuinely and honestly
try to understand your word
father you speak to everyone who has a
question who has a concern
speak to that person father and bring
light and knowledge
and assurance for everyone that he or
she may know
that a life in the hand of christ is a
safe life
let's talk to mccurdy in a very special
way blessed studies bless her family
make her blessing to others and for
everyone who listened bless each person
individually father and then as a family
if other nations were represented by the
audience bless those nations father
keep us faithful one day at a time save
us when you come
along with those who've come to christ
because of us
in jesus name i pray amen
amen amen thank you elder skeet and
thank you for those of you that tuned in
via zoom and
youtube um i see so many names
sister shea we already saw before emma
hurley sister stacy and brown
we're looking forward to having you june
19.
we'll speak about that later everyone
sister ingrid and
rodney smith brother robinson altino
and sister anna altino we appreciate
your presence
we appreciate your presence now we are
going to have
a piece of music by brother kevin gomez
he is 28 years old
he's studying theology he currently
works as a painter
and a construction worker and he is an
active minister
of music so please welcome brother
kevin gomez
[Music]
so
now than it has ever been
i can almost hear the trumpet
[Music]
[Applause]
his children
the heart in christ
shall be quickly changed i don't mean i
cry
when jesus comes
[Music]
i look around me
i see prophecies full of feelings
everywhere
and the signs of the town
i can almost hear
the bride of christ shall rise
[Music]
when jesus steps
surprised
[Music]
didn't mean i cried
when jesus comes again
and then those that remain
shall be quickly changed
when jesus comes again
when jesus comes
again
amen he's coming again
hallelujah jesus is coming again
at that midnight cry brother gomez
thank you for that powerful rendition of
the song
midnight cry may the lord continue to
bless
and keep you i know the last time elder
skeet was on he so greatly appreciated
your ministry
even as you as you ministered the holy
city that
beautiful anthem and friends we are just
so happy that you are with us and we
pray that you have been blessed
by this program we thank god for his
presence
and his leading today and i express
sincere thanks to elder randy skeet
for answering the questions to the
inspiration of the holy spirit giving
freely
of his time despite the the the the
tightness of his schedule
um we are so thankful that you were ever
willing to do the work of the lord and
may the lord continue to strengthen and
bless you and your family
elder skeet thank you so much sister
alana kwashi for blessing us with
wonderful merciful savior
and thank you sister chelsea jack for
assisting me in answering the questions
i appreciate you taking this role
and for also adding personal experiences
and commentary
brother kevin gomez we appreciate you
ministering
ministering midnight cry when jesus
comes again and thank you in advance
sister
crystal gilbert you heard her father axe
the question i thought he was galaxyj2
elder gilbert asked a question about
temperance and this afternoon his
daughter sister crystal gilbert
will be giving us the closing prayer i
also extend thanks to cousin errol henry
for ensuring reverence was preserved
throughout this program making sure we
had smooth transitions
and persons were spotlighted accordingly
and thank you to everyone that has
participated
whether it may be asked me been asking a
question live on the zoom or posting
your question
in the chat and i thank you all for also
subscribing and following and liking and
sharing we want this message
to go to all the world now i will
quickly invite
all of you to the next
episode also the pillars
series by god's grace sabbath uh
june 19th at two o'clock p.m we are
having
episode six of the field of pillar
series i should say this when i
initially set out to do this series it
would only be
for seven months so from february to
august
um and only the second sabbath of the
month
and then you know we ended up doing
lives every other sabbath so twice a
month
and doing special editions uh so this is
episode six and we'll be talking about
the spirit of prophecy with dr walter
weith
brother robinson altina will be
ministering on piano sister stacy and
brown will be delivering a poem brother
jonathan
and i will be by god's grace doing a
peace brother anthony ralph will be
assisting me in asking the questions
and brother jonathan weeks will be doing
the closing prayer you
um herbie make mention of his wife
sister
sasha shay weeks which has been posing
questions and
encouraging messages in the chat so we
look forward to seeing you all
sabbath june 19th at 2 o'clock p.m
the zoom information is here the id is
679-742-1793 and the password is one two
three four
five seven this program is also live
stream to twitch so if you're on twitch
you can catch this live stream at the
word inspired and it's on youtube and
facebook
as denise mckerchen and on facebook i
also have of the word inspired
page so you can find it there thank you
so much for tuning in thus far
sister crystal gilbert you can close us
off with a word
of prayer thank you so very much thank
you
please buy your heads and close your
eyes for prayer
our father in heaven dear lord we thank
you so much for
allowing us to come here lord on this
your holy sabbath day
we thank you for your goodness and we
thank you for your mercy lord
as you didn't know us time you're
speaking to us lord please help us to
heed your message so that we too can be
saved and most of all lord please help
us to be spiritually awake
in these troublesome times we thank you
for elderski
and his service to you lord we thank you
for denisha and her faithfulness
and to all the young people that
continuously support this program world
please and camp around all of them and
continue to watch over them
as well as everyone within the hearing
of this program in jesus name i pray
amen amen amen and i just realized i
failed to thank my mom mom thank you so
much for your prayers and
helping this program happen i know
we came straight from church and quickly
set up so thank you mom and all of you
that helped
make this program possible may god
continue to bless you all
and i pray that you have a wonderful
rest of the sabbath day to those of you
that watch the replay
feel free to share like and subscribe
god bless thank you all